the remnants of what was supposed to be
a celebration in this Baltimore
neighborhood barbecue and children's
bikes now the gloves of Medics sit among
them a sign of another mass shooting
currently we're still at 30 victims ages
range from 13 to 32 nine victims remain
at area hospitals in various conditions
two victims have been pronounced
deceased
nearly half the victims were under the
age of 18. police believe there was more
than one shooter they have not been
found officials say this is just another
example of America's gun violence
epidemic this is insanity this cannot
cannot be the society that we are
expected to live in we have to do better
Maryland has some of the strictest gun
laws in the country but officials say
that makes little difference this year
alone the Baltimore Police Department
has seized
1345 illegal guns that were in the hands
of people that should not have them that
had them anyway because they're so easy
for them to obtain Baltimore is the
second deadliest city in the U.S and one
of the poorest experts say it all helps
create the cycle of violence poverty
unemployment an education system that
continues to not work for all of the
children here but at the same time in
order for us to keep the community safe
including those children
it is really a pressing matter it is
urgent that we get a handle on the
violence the police union says a big
part of the problem is that they are
short staffed they are down 700 officers
and hiring here has been difficult but
the problem is years old and the
Baltimore PD has had problems of its own
in 2015 large protests followed the
death of Freddie gray in police custody
more recently a massive police
corruption Scandal more than a dozen
officers arrested for robbing drug
dealers of drugs and guns to sell them
themselves Baltimore is a city in crisis
adding 30 more gun violence victims to
an already long list
Al Jazeera